hallo wir sind heute in berlin und
zeigen euch geschäfte die man in den
straßen in deutschland sieht das ist
eine bank das ist die sparkasse die
sparkasse ist eine besonders populäre
bank in deutschland
ich gehe in die sparkasse geld abheben
das ist das zeichen von einer apotheke
in deutschland wenn wir dieses zeichen
wird dann habt ihr eine apotheke
gefunden
der türke hat einen eigenen
fahrradständer wachsen darf man nur in
den öffnungszeiten der apotheke
benutzten nämlich samstags um 13 uhr und
in der woche bis 19 uhr
jetzt stehen wir vor einer praxis die
praxis ist ein ort wo man sich
medizinisch verhandeln es gibt zum
beispiel eine arztpraxis eine
zahnarztpraxis oder wie hier eine
physiotherapiepraxis das ist eine
bäckerei bäckereien sind sehr populär in
deutschland in der bäckerei kaufmann
brote und brötchen mainz weit kann man
auch drinnen und draußen sitzen hier
stehen wir vor einem flottengeschäft
das ist eine schaufeln prof hier können
wir klamotten ansehen auswählen an
probieren und kaufen dafür ist eine
billig spitze real
hier kommt wird alles vier euro früher
hat sie alle drei euro gekostet aber
jetzt ist sie teurer geworden
spaghetti vier euro regazzoni vier euro
genau vier euro tortellini vier euro
alle pizza vier euro diese art von
geschäfte sind sehr populär und es gibt
viele verschiedene worte dafür
döner imbiss boehner ladendieb abladen
das hier ist ein gemüse geben
das heißt es gibt weder fleisch gemüse
drin das populärste was man hier essen
kann ist eine döner tasche im fladenbrot
und einen dürren gerollt normalerweise
kosten die zwischen drei und vier euro
dafür ist ein schreibwarenladen
im schreibwarenladen kaufmann
schreibwaren zum beispiel stifte hefte
bücher zum beispiel sachen für die
schule dafür ist eine buchhandlung die
buchhandlung ianos behauptet ich werde
hier noch nie drin gewesen
das stimmt aber gar nicht was sagt ihr
könnt toll deutschlernen klugen sprüchen
auf postkarten so toll organisiert zum
beispiel mehr geht immer das ist witzig
weil mehr und mehr klingt ähnlich
das hier ist ein computerladen hier
reparieren sie alles apple pc tastatur
das hier ist eine eisdiele in der
eisdiele kaufmann 1 das ist ein
fahrradgeschäft in dem fahrradgeschäft
dianas sein fahrrad gekauft
im fahrradgeschäft kann man fahrräder
kaufen aber auch fahrrad zubehör wie
schlösser fahrradhelme oder fahrt
kleidung
das ist ein schallplatten laden jannis
steht staunend vor dem schaufenster des
schallplatten lagen in diesem
schallplatten lagen gibt sich viele
welten des schallplatten- und bücher
dieser schatten lagen steht für text und
volksmusik ein stück brasilien in berlin
das bazl waxing studio
hier könnt ihr eure lässigen körperhaare
entfernen lassen und verband ohne termin
das ist ein möbelgeschäft in berlin
kannst du dich entscheiden entweder
kaufst du dir teure hipster möbel oder
du baust du dir selber aus einer
europalette das ist ein supermarkt
dieser supermarkt ist von 8 bis 22 uhr
geöffnet samstags bis 23 uhr sonntag
haben alle supermärkte in deutschland
geschlossen
nur in bahnhöfen haben supermärkte
manchmal auch sonntags geöffnet
das hier ist ein restaurant in berlin
sind die restaurants oft ein bisschen
günstiger als in anderen städten ist ein
waschsalon
ich gehe in den waschsalon im bass
verlangen kann man seine wäsche waschen
eine weste kostet drei euro fünfzig das
ist das überraschungsgeschenk artikel
geschäft
im geschenk kapitel geschäft gibt es
verkleidungen aller art das ist mein
restaurant paris fest ich stehe vor
einem blumengeschäft im blumengeschäft
kenianers blumen für karry kaufen oder
kerry campbell für jahres kaufen machen
wir aber nie
das ist ein später später halten später
weil sie auch spät noch auf haben sie
verkaufen vor allem getränke aber auch
tabak und snacks in anderen regionen von
deutschland heißen diese läden anders zb
vier buden oder trinkhalm in manchen
regionen gibt es gar keine später zum
beispiel in bestimmten regionen von sid
deutschlands dort gibt es solche läden
gar nicht dieses geschäft ist eine
mischung zwischen einem später und einem
supermarkt es ist 24 stunden am tag
geöffnet und es ist typisch für berlin
hier kann man viele dinge kaufen die man
auch im normalen sommer kaufen land wie
zum beispiel tomatensoße aber zusätzlich
kann man auch viele türkische dinge
kaufen wie fladenbrot jetzt fehlt nur
noch ein friseur janus braucht dringend
einen neuen haarschnitt janosch geht zum
friseur um einen termin zu machen
oh nein bisher hat schon zu das wars mit
unserer heutigen episode heinz höher
termin aber vielleicht wechseln werden
dann werdet ihr zetteln und abonniert
die german für viele neue videos liebe
grüße ja bei uns auf der straße ist
immer so laut
[Musik]